aha hasta tarde esta familia adelante no
venimos and era lo que el SI SE y por
ello no toten venimos protest archons ah
hell yes a rebel a safe attract a vida
que pido una disculpa ya basta Eligon
mode Al Fatah nosotros y me to stop in
blazes el estado femina community Pecos
we were horrendous ponte en New Hope de
pana million vol de ser por yo yo yo
come creates more jobs than any other
than any other person at it that I've
ever that I've ever heard about or read
about this hotel of his is going to
create a lot of jobs this hotel pulls us
down there what those jobs go away and
leave he'll change America make America
great again how cool shops are put on
going to illegal immigrants I had a
friend of mine I wanted to be a
babysitter wouldn't do it because the
Mexican nanny mafia doctor from dawn